all right Keith is with us Keith's in
Kansas City
hey Keith merry Christmas to you how can
I help sir I have a question a surgery I
need to get down on my shoulder and this
year we got a $5,000 out-of-pocket that
we have to pay and a $500 deductible
this year I've met my deductible and
I've paid $2,900 I'd be out of pocket if
I get the surgery done now at the most
I'd be looking at $2,000 to do it if I
wait till the first of the year I can be
you know looking up to $5,500 time I pay
the deductible and out-of-pocket I don't
have the cash to do it right now so I
was wondering I know you don't like say
getting a loan but if I had a loan from
the credit union or something like that
and then I could pay back the first of
the year when I got my tax return if
that would be something that I should do
or should I just wait it out what's
wrong your trunk just to have it that or
from popping out of place and stuff like
that okay Alex yeah that's a painful
it's a painful thing how old are ya
thirty-three okay and on your merry up
yes what's your household income we make
forty-three thousand a year and so the
surgery would be scheduled before the
end of the year yeah they can schedule
me they called in so they can get me in
on the 11th and and I know it's not you
know I guess that I could go to the
first a year is not something I have to
as I know I may not just bill you I mean
you don't have to go in with the cash
and put it on the counter to get surgery
do well no but I just thought that you
know I mean I can be billed for but you
know if I I just thought that it'd be
better I need a better deal basically
now so I didn't know no I mean you can
Lincoln just billion and you still get
the savings you'll just have to pay them
pay the bill when you get the bill in
January right yeah well I was just
looking at paying like I figured that
I'd be looking at payment
thirty-five hundred dollars more no
because I've already met everybody you
must understand if you get the surgery
done now they'll just send you a bill
won't they right right yeah that's not
extra the date of the surgeries when the
when the deductible applies not when you
pay the bill all right you see what I'm
saying well yeah I do so you get the
savings that you're trying to get by
just going over there and getting the
surgery and they send you a bill and you
got to pay it in January uh-huh right
but I was just
I knew the surgery would cost more
knowing that because if I get to the
five thousand dollars out-of-pocket
which it does not cost more that's what
I'm trying to tell you if you go get
that's when you have the surgery that
bait is based on whether this is your
out of pocket you've met your deductible
right yeah for this year yeah and so as
long as you have the surgery this year
not when you pay the bill yeah as long
as you have the surgery this year that
saves you what you're trying to save not
when you pay the bill uh-huh you follow
me okay right right yeah so go and have
the surgery tell them to send you a bill
and go deliver pizzas or have a garage
sale or something and pay the bill in
January okay okay you know you can make
a little extra money pick up some
overtime take an extra job have a garage
sale do some stuff and pay the bill in
January but go ahead and get the surgery
and get your savings I agree with you to
try to take advantage of the savings
why are you know before you're you're in
thing but no you don't have to borrow
money to do it that's what I'm not so
that's what I'm I mean they're gonna
send you a bill just tell them that it
puts send it to my insurance most people
don't pay it for 90 days anyway and so
no don't go borrow money at the credit
union that's answered your question yes
go have the surgery that's the answer
your question yes go work extra yes have
a garage sale yes put some stuff on
Craigslist
yes pay cash for the bill when it comes
in in the after the first of the year
but you've still gotten all of your
year-end save
by having them already met your
deductible thanks for the call